hello and welcome to yet another tea
session not so long probably as the one
before I only got 30 minutes until I do
something but I figured in the 30
minutes I might as well make a quick
video so let's get rollin what are we
going to try like 3 plus 1 or something
or 3 plus 2 let's fry 3 plus 2 we get
somebody yeah we get somebody i have no
sound this is a bit odd oh no I have
sound that's good so let's see if I can
do something good in the Sicilian after
I've looked at this for month before the
fight like Magnus cause
yeah so
yeah by the way if you're interested in
that opening course it's still on sale
for think about two days so if you want
to grab it form the sales price make
sure to do it in the near future so um
let's get this what is this we have the
main line here right with Bishop g5 then
Bishop f6 Bishop f6 this is more of a
strategically focused line where you
don't need to know yeah we don't need to
know that much theory actually I mean
you should know some stuff but it's not
comparable to the lines where the double
pawn is created right away
so this g6o has been played by Magnus
this year against Wesley so I adopted
this for the repertoire white no usually
plays g3 this is a little bit strange
because now h4 is really hanging I think
why can I not take it I don't know let
me take the pawn
before it was always covered due to
Queen age five you know but now I can
take it so I'm going to put the Bishop
to g7 where this safeguarding my king
for yeah for good measure
I shouldn't really ever happen anything
against my king with having a dark
square bishop
the tea is unbelievably hot wow I wonder
ever actually managed to to drink it in
there in a 30-minute session but we'll
see what happens if not I have to take
it with me okay um yeah here before I
guess let's open up the play against
White's King that should be
a prime objective here it's actually
White's King that is probably more more
endangered
Knight to g4 while I can check here for
some awkwardness
many things are awkward okay Knight f6
would be made basically so I cannot
allow that but I can take here and I can
check I can check on g5
yeah both seems very good actually
the check is a bit more complicated okay
let's let's do the check
simply hacking g-form and taking on c3
is of course a large advantage but this
is good yeah because he has to play
Knight e3 otherwise I'm just taking g4
and whatever Knight move doesn't really
help him like Knight e3 here I can just
take on c3 or oh it's it's all backwards
now um I take here first on c3 because
I'd like to get him to take with the
pawn yeah and now I feel the easiest
solution is to take d5 but there are
many good things here that I can play
now I think I'll just take it this is
the in some way they keep it simple
approach now an interesting way to play
would be e form simply busting open the
long diagonal but just 97 is of course
good so let's go 97
is preparing f-5e form do it slowly
I mean white skin position again is
pretty awkward and it might not be the
the quickest way to kill a white but it
looks like a reliable way
yeah why does I would have reasonable
ideas here
yet you just allow me to take edge form
which is pretty pretty strange no I'm
here you should just cover it with g3
now now my ideas to play a form and then
Queen f6 next and then c3 is collapsing
with the of course fatal consequences
there's just no way to cover c3
yum this is I expect the ping
rocky for I'm sorry Rock deform the
Stallone
[Music]
that was a misstep here he can play rook
f1 rook t4 and still he didn't do that
yeah that was that was still a way to
continue the game not with much hope but
at least it's it's a way to hang on
[Music]
yeah
probably just take take here on a two
and then Luca PA to be true maybe if he
goes Queen h2 or h3 um yam Luke a one
maybe a me cannot take this if he goes
with the King to the earth to the Queen
to the h-file there's not a real threat
even I can just ignore this if I want
okay um
maybe okay
just h5 is it's enough to stop
everything there
so h5 or yep h5
yeah I can take H she can
take this pawn maybe okay come on let's
keep it very simple
energy five is the crystal Queen right
weenus nor squares
you know ya just cannot give me age for
that's just not possible okay now um I
cannot click rematch may be locked off
I'm always okay with the rematch but I'm
going for a new game let's see
Valley Vani
what's going on no just just
everything's fine here right yeah looks
good yeah let's try the Rogozin if we
get it can also the Catalan is very
frequently seen nowadays so the
recursion I'm still a little bit shaky
with the the with the theory there
sometimes I confuse move orders because
I was a of course and the co-author of
the new Musa Andrew golden repertoire on
chasuble but I still tend to forget to
the line sometimes yeah here for example
what exactly was the right right
continuation there is more than one
reasonable way to play this position
that is absolutely clear but I don't
quite know what it was so I'm going to
just take him and so now maybe e5 is
that a possibility and it cannot be
terrible I think this is actually a line
castles takes 95 I think is a line
[Music]
yeah sometimes confused there because at
the time I was working on the names of a
Gordon repertoire and the Magna Sicilian
repertoire at the same time and it was
it was really really lots of things
happening at the same time and this is
not as clear in my mind as some other
things that I have examined
you know so ever for those things that
I'm studying for my opening repertoires
on chasuble this is mostly short-term
memory yeah I remember everything
basically shortly after I've written it
but if I'm if I'm doing something new
this is so to say the memory banks get
immediately it gets replaced immediately
by by the new thing now how do we play
this him he's got 95 sometimes at night
he form both somehow here on the agenda
I think I should get this back
94 queen g6 should not be a problem and
d5 95 of course not at all a problem
I didn't like this liability
the bishop is always
yeah dependent on the night to cover it
and we don't have it like this now 95 I
thought I can always go queen g6 so um
what about Bishop g4 here yeah that's a
thing shouldn't be too bad
you have to be very of the of the
diagonal here sorry of the fourth-ranked
here the Queen yeah but there is no
technical ways like d5 is not a problem
yeah here but he's got the bishop still
on c4
[Music]
so it doesn't look like something going
on yeah white has to be a little bit
careful here with the central pawn right
the central pawn is shaky you know I'm
threatening to take the knight and then
take the pawn immediately I couldn't
take it because there was always a
tactic with Bishop takes f7 at the end
so that's unpainted
unpainted by clicking and chasuble on
only chest it's probably not the best
way to do it okay so he's attacking um
he's attacking the bishop
um I'm a little bit it's a little bit
it's a little bit shaky this thing but
if I take here and take on e5
with the night I mean something bad
happening to me I don't quite see it
95 26
see as a problem at the moment he cannot
go rook to e1 I'm simply on the square
with with the bishop otherwise rook t1
would have looked maybe like an issue
but yeah I don't see a tactic and I'm
simply threatening to take on mayor
maybe not I don't think I'm trying I'm
threatening I'm threatening to take on
c4 and then continue okay so let's move
him
the bishop is nicely placed on one c6.r
what about taking on c4 here that is
definitely a consideration
is stronger than the nighttime
you
the pin looks extremely problematic
No
what is the best way to do this pawn
takes looks very loose I mean like the
kingside looks loose and fortunately I
cannot take c4 as you can take the Queen
so so I'm taking taking with the Queen
Oh interesting I thought you'd take me
five
I can even trade you right
now let's go see five if he takes a
truck see a jazz a rope trade because he
cannot rest back wrong medicine he has
to allow the trade create first again
threatening mate
and now
we do this
probably taken before so that he cannot
go before and I'm currently cutting off
the King so
is not able to help
King the seven I guess just approaching
don't want to give him this one
let's go up
no porn for you
and now
see eight should
medli window porn
you know I mean
now it's the easiest thing route just
turn the exchange for the winning King
and pawn ending
ah
all right so let's go for a rematch you
have to keep an eye on the on the clock
but I still got a bit of time
hmm okay
soon
we got the double fianchetto this is one
of the lines in the in my keep it simple
D for that is scoring absolutely heavily
because black players have all kinds of
ideas about the position but but most of
them are not great
now there is the SS bloody Knight g4 I
think knight c6 is right I can never
really remember this I get I get to this
position quite a bit because they've
played five and basically blunder the
pawn and then then they check oh my god
I've landed upon and then Knight g4 is
often the trick move that they still
have but I think knight c6 is right I've
got this wrong more than once this one
okay
why would that work
mmm
the easiest thing is to take f7 right
come on let's take f7
it's a bit weird everything but f7
should just be a good move
all right does he have something
miraculous like
night xf2 don't believe it
so taking g7
to drop
now um you would take with the rook or I
have to check Queen f6 at the end this
is something that has to be taken into
account
because my the dark squares here are
slightly weak so you have to keep this
in mind maybe he can go night if five
okay now this one just trying to be
annoying
it's got a bit of development here yeah
this is
this is true rookie aides coming
you
you know after I think you play this a
little bit more
recked if I give him give him time oh I
blundered that one
yeah I am still going to go with this
overall concept I want to try to use
concrete features of the position like
94 coming but as a blonde at 93 as well
I didn't see this move coming
it's a truly odd position I wanted to go
nightly forearm in this this kind of
scenario
[Music]
it's really shame because obviously the
opening was more or less over if you do
it correctly but I then I played more
than one nonsensical move
you
very bad position maybe you can even
Knight f2 as possible here
and night f2 is actually a move
Hey that is that is a real shame
given how how terrible this is I mean
you just blundered the the big center
pawn in one move
you
you
really awful
we should be one
yeah I would like to play Bishop c4 but
that is not quite legal
Queen f7 now we can actually play rook
evade unfortunately as he six covered by
the bishop
[Music]
said
okay Queenie seven not
subtle threat but
with fret
and now unfortunately Queen f3 is the
threat
which
it's again pretty awful
you know now you overlook that but it
doesn't matter really it's still a
complete win
Prine f1 still wins
this is increment right yet I could
resign you actually
yeah soulmate yeah this is a [ __ ] this
is stuff like that it's not really
um yeah it's like
we are necessary I just wonder if I can
do much more yawn I have seven I mean
this is this is just very good yeah but
I acquitted quickly lost the threat this
this and probably here I have to improve
g4 I need to improve I actually did not
see that c2 was hanging is the problem
like something normal it's just like
plus one point for their Luke c1 it's
pretty it's pretty clear that I should
be better in such a scenario but I what
I wanted to do I just always looked at
c2 and the g4 and c2 were hanging but I
wanted to address or the Eco was back
and then I wanted to go an idea for you
know that was my idea and I just
overlooked that he can take anyone okay
so let's create a new game and these
kind of things are always a little bit
annoying because they basically just say
here take the point yeah and you just
don't take it it's like
basically playing a game where the
opponent says okay I just I just want to
do this it's fine and then you then you
just don't take the opportunities that
they give to you on a silver plate
it's always very annoying okay now I
don't quite know what blacks idea is
here because that looks a pretty strange
Catalan okay so does he want to play
what does he want to play I don't know
I just prepare you for we
I can take a couple of times Wow
what that's that must have been some
drug that he has taken but non castling
long is this really that's that's I
don't quite know what to say about this
this pretty
same
you
you
come where are you going now with
now before I can go a three before here
for something simple but you can also
think about more more drastic measures
let's do this and not spend ages this is
a very good position for white
in thinking longer is probably not
really leading to it's a significantly
better solution than the one that are
already played
it's actually pretty close to 90 85
being okay like 95 be should be 595 25
Bishop f4 and then look see one just
like yeah everything on the King I don't
think it works but this is a motif that
um just needs like one additional tempo
at you to probably work
a move that is probably useful here is
age three maybe he's got Bishop g4 at
some point I can just go age three me
leg is stuck with the King on c8 and my
coming moves are not exactly rocket
science just like I cants
give me the bishop pair no okay so he
just gave me this move form for nothing
okay
I can just take you five then right why
not
ready to go a forum here we go
here we go
let u e5 it's just I
the thing
it has a square I didn't didn't even see
that I thought I thought he would
already kick it in now
you didn't
okay
you
I can't get this in the game
okay it is really bad so let's go on for
a new opponent is his left he's left the
building so the same so I think I can
get one more game in and stir
yeah be
on schedule ultra chess master 3000 I'm
glad that I'm not playing against ultra
Chessmaster 4000 that must have been
terrible
and all in all in caps
almost like a Donald Trump tweet
now what's happening okay I did this I
really have to look this up again in my
repertoire I keep getting this in my
blitz games and I absolutely forget my
own recommendation yeah d take C 5 is a
good line for white it's really really
fine and I keep forgetting why why am I
actually doing this is that my mistake I
mean this is definitely a bit better for
white
I'm really not certain if that was what
I recommended
I mean this is not extremely important
because no matter what you do you will
always have a position with this type of
pawn structure which is some known for
ages to be quite comfortable for white
but there's a difference between quite
comfortable and just yam have a large
advantage and this is not a large
advantage for white
I really have to have to check this
Jim but the good thing is if you know
your repertoire with white and you have
what
No
taking this if you know your your things
the clock advantage the time advantage
is just sometimes enormous I've played
this d4 Knight e3 g3 keep it simple sai
repertoire in in hundreds of bullet
games 1+1 and I sometimes ended up
winning with 40 seconds on the clock
because like I played like 50 to 20
moves of what I know and then the rest
often was conversion
now this is also not very good Jam
because blacks pawn structure no matter
what he does it's always going to be a
somewhat weakened pawn structure it's
not possible to get back to to normal
structures now because f5 is on its own
and if he goes is six which he which it
does him now let's go up do you one um
then d6 is going to be vulnerable d6 is
not always going to be a problem as we
have know in many Sicilian lines this is
just not a real weakness but here there
was very little dynamic counter chances
that and you can imagine here for black
it's also that his King position is a
bit weak I could have taken only four I
mean maybe this would have been even
stronger getting the pawn to e4 actually
but okay this is some
still nice for white and I'm two minutes
up on the clock in a three minute game
that's pretty pretty damning what are
you doing here buddy you got to a second
increment
okay so he has taken on c3 finally
now do you play before here um yeah
and this one yeah I think I'm going to
take because oops this is actually a
triple attack D 6 a 7 and a e 4 and I
wonder which pawn he intends to give me
or decides to give me don't think he
intended any of that really so take this
and I guess I'll take t5
just oops just keep this porn um yeah
Queen to b3 looks easiest
a good way to play is like a three Queen
III maybe
[Music]
what is going on the ultra chess master
has got some
some malfunction going on
now what are we going to do here
Queen d5 maybe could be a thing
you
yeah that
default under control and before yeah it
was not a pawn that he wanted to take
rook t4 is also a good move he cannot go
f5 and this is just keeping everything
under control
so yeah the ending is of course better
but better is not really
cutting it maybe
you know but it is really very good so
let's do it
g4 is intending to march the king of the
board I came I actually missed that f5
is immediately attacking my rook which
is a bit of a shame
okay
it's still very good but not as good as
a as I initially thought
yeah rook g5 is a is a trade
rooks which wins pretty easily but can
also just take every single pawn
yeah what is the easiest way to do it
King takes maybe and
get the get the E and F pawn up the
board
it's just going to be
- quick um yeah let's switch this over
you
you
the two connected pawns are just too
quick
you
you
and fortunately I cannot take the
because I really have to run so I hope
you enjoyed the session it was a yeah 37
minutes um I don't mind to do it longer
I still have tea but I have to do
something and but I wanted to get a
quick video out so to keep you guys on
track oh I just see that you cannot see
the times correctly yeah that's not good
I have to check this looks a little bit
odd I think it's only after the game is
over right okay anyway thanks for
watching guys I'll be back tomorrow
hopefully bye bye